hey youtubers it's Charlie so today for
my bonus video I wanted to talk a little
bit about Spider Man coming home which
is a storyline in Ezekiel Sims which I
think there's a good chance is going to
be the villain of the new Spider Man
film
he's like my new best theory right now
just because he's so much more complex
than say like vulture and if Michael
Keaton is going to be playing him I
think it'd be a lot easier for Sony and
Marvel to get him if you were playing a
much more interesting character but the
thing about the storyline coming home is
that there's this big supernatural
aspect and I don't know how supernatural
they want to make this new Spider Man
solo trilogy so if you've never read it
Spiderman coming home was written by J
michael Straczynski it's probably one of
the greatest spider-man stories of all
time maybe not the greatest but
definitely one of the best and it's
illustrated by John Romita Jr so it
looks amazing but the whole idea of the
Run was to refresh the spider-man
character give him a whole new
supporting cast of characters there have
been all these terrible spider-man
stories in the 90s that people just did
not like so they're like okay we need to
reboot this character so what does that
sound like that sounds like what's going
on in the movies the spider-man movie
franchise has gone through a lot of
iterations in the last 10 years that
haven't been quite as fulfilling and
successful as they want them to be so
now they're rebooting the character
refreshing just the same way they did
with spider-man
coming home so what a coincidence that
the title of the new spider-man movie is
spider-man homecoming the cool thing
about the Ezekiel Sims character is that
he has all the same powers as spider-man
but he's kind of like Uncle Ben he's
almost like a darker version of Uncle
Ben someone who took his powers and used
them for personal gain
so he's super rich and he kind of calls
Peter on his philosophy like look look
at what you could accomplish if you
embraced your abilities a good example
that is right now in the spider-man
comics Peter Parker is head of parker
industries now that's a whole other
story but it's just like a version of
spider-man that's more like iron man
rich industrialist spider-man with a
giant company so a long time before that
when the Ezekiel character debuted
during this coming home run he tried to
call Peter on some of his look
you could be so much greater than this
now the really interesting thing where
it gets really supernatural is where it
explains how Ezekiel got his spider-man
powers the way Ezekiel got his powers is
a little bit closer to the way Black
Panther
his powers he's connected to the Panther
God with a totem which he gives him all
these mystical abilities like king of
the Dead Black Panther but in the comics
the original origin story of Spider Man
is that he gets bit by a radioactive
spider
so Ezekiel tells Peter look I don't
think that you got your powers because
of that radioactive spider I think that
spider itself was trying to give you its
powers so you can see it gets really
weird and supernatural I don't think
they're gonna go that off-book with the
new Spider Man films but I do like the
theory that they're gonna weave in
Anna's II kiyul type character like a
more sinister version of Uncle Ben
now Ezekiel wants to help spider-man but
morally they're at an impasse because
what happened to Ezekiel is is he
decided that he needed a company behind
him he needed resources to be a hero so
he got his powers but then was like okay
I'm gonna use my abilities to build this
company then I'm gonna be a hero but the
day-to-day of running his company got so
busy that he started using his powers
less and less so you get the idea he
turned into the man and stop being a
hero so it's like a good example of what
could happen to Peter if he fell off the
hero's path like he's on the way to
becoming this great superhero but if you
get sidetracked by money and fame it all
goes to the funny thing about the
run is that you know a lot of
spider-man's biggest villains are based
on animals I think I used this Deadpool
panel in the Deadpool video that I did
last week just a joke on villains like
the lizard the Rhino you get the idea
during this coming home run during this
Ezekiel run the way they explained it is
is that a lot of other totems that were
feeding those villains were the reason
why they were based on animals so it's
almost like they're taking the idea of
the Panther totem and the Black Panther
comics and using it in the spider-man
universe and that actually fed into the
spider verse although I know a lot of
people weren't big fans of the spider
birth storylines but spider verse is a
completely separate thing and I don't
know necessarily that the new movies
would go in the direction of
spider-verse either because it gets
super complicated I think they're gonna
try and keep it relatively simple but
they might tease some ideas of
spider-verse but here's my big question
for you guys would you rather see
Michael Keaton if he's going to be the
spider-man villain play a version of say
like the vulture or would you rather see
them introduce the Ezekiel character
because they really did rewrite a lot of
spider-man Lord during that Ezekiel run
like spider-man is not really a
supernatural character but they turned
him into one during that run so I think
it really depends on how precious the
original spider-man origins
story is to you like if you don't mind
them changing a few things that's not
too bad but you have to remember for any
movie they tend to make it a little more
linear a little easier to follow so I
think they're gonna let Doctor Strange
be the supernatural character of the
Marvel Universe spider-man will still be
pretty straight up based in science so
really bright Peter Parker mechanical
web-shooters stark tech suit probably
not a lot of supernatural stuff gonna be
happening and I just love the idea of
Michael Keaton playing someone who's in
antagonist without being a villain who's
kind of like this advisor trying to
influence spider-man to go in a slightly
darker direction while at the same time
having a lot of good ideas like look at
all these things I can do with my
company if you really took advantage of
your abilities you could be one of the
greatest heroes in the history of the
earth all comes back to great power
great responsibilities you know should
you seek great power just for the sake
of having great power but officially
nothing's been confirmed they're still
trying to lock down Michael Keaton so I
don't know even if they do get him if
they'll reveal who he's playing they
might keep that pretty close to the best
but the spider-man movies coming next
year so they're actually gonna start
shooting it pretty soon so just expect
them to start dropping some Spiderman
bombs later this year it's gonna be
really exciting in related news the
flash is back tonight so I'll be posting
a video for that after the episode airs
be sure to subscribe to get it
if there's any other Marvel videos that
you guys want this week I'm working on
some Doctor Strange I know the Supergirl
finale just happened yes it does seem
like they just introduced Power Girl and
they just introduced Ezreal on Gotham so
I'll try to make some videos about that
too there's a whole bunch of stuff
happening this week I'm actually really
excited while you guys wait for me to
post that flash video you can click here
to learn more about Marvel phase 4 Kevin
Feige has been teasing all kinds of
awesome stuff and you can click here to
learn more about the spider-man
homecoming movie thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you